josé retrace beau voulez vous prendre
pour époux marie masure est ici
présentes oui
marie mesuré de voulez vous prendre pour
époux joseph strasbourg ici présents oui
je vous déclare unis par les liens du
mariage
non pas unis par des liens qui
retiennent et enchaîne mais unis par le
désir que vous avez eu du bonheur l'un
de l'autre
l'un par l'autre et l'un pour l'autre
les gens heureux n'ont pas d'histoire
la vôtre celle que vous avez vécu
ensemble à aujourd'hui 70 ans
voilà on dit toujours que tu n'es pas
gracieux et c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
les professionnels tu te fais pas c'est
toujours pour mes champs alors que tu ne
l'est pas du tout tu ça tu as toujours
été très bobo en moi répond très gentil
tu m'a gâté
ici et là des musulmans et ben mitchell
donc si tu joues immeubles durables
mais combien de fois on m'a dit en me
gillot ris de veau pas de facile à vivre
combien de fois on m'a dit ça possible
ya des fois
je vais vous le connaissez mal
puisque j'ai répondu c'est tout
mais moi je ne sais pas ce que tu penses
de voix on n'a pas trop souffert au nom
n'avait pas dit jean billon en zone 1
oui c'est bien d'y indien avait dire
avez vous encore plus longtemps j'ai un
micro d'espn
on a droit cousin qu on m a bien sûr moi
pour les b pour l'équité
enfin j'ai toujours bien entendu ces
belles choses
tu as compris
[Applaudissements]
j'étais célibataire j'allais souvent
déjeuner chez mon oncle et ma tante est
naturellement à ce moment là j'ai pu
faire connaissance de marie et j'ai pu
apprécier ses qualités je me suis pas
trompé la preuve j'ai vu que c'était une
travailleuse j'ai vu qu'elle était
gentille qu'elle était douce facile à
manier un remarqué que je lis pas manié
asseman mavin facile facile quoi enfin
j'ai constaté une chose que j'étais
protesté femme qu'il fallait et j'ai dit
à mes parents
demandent demandé demandé mari comme ma
mère et sa mère étaient cousines
germaines en somme on était cousin
réussi germain heureusement on était en
encore et alors ça s'est fait très
rapidement alors le 17 le 24 février on
s'est mariés
[Musique]
alors là tu es belle douce à
belchamp ça va alors on rentre à la
maison rien
ay l'aca n'a pas eu d'enfants enfin on a
conservé toujours des relations
avec tout notre ami surtout du côté de
marins de ma mère du côté des bears est
drôlement du mon père j'ai jamais je
n'ai pas connu pour ainsi dire de
parents de mon père sait pas pourquoi je
dirais une chose j'ai jamais été très
ouvert avec mon père mon père
il me disait quelques fois tu le feras
jamais rien de propre
parce que pourtant j'étais pas méchant
seulement il était très sévère et puis
enfin je ne sais pas à moi il me dit
toujours tu vas jamais rien de propre et
g à 45 ans
à 45 ans il m'a dit mais tu sais de
faire quelque chose un
code et sur ce ton ami tu dis parce que
leurs jambes étaient un peu humide et
pendant les vacances j'ai acheté du sud
roussillon j'ai tapissé leur semble avec
du fibrociment recouvert de papier en
chine et où j'ai fait ça quand j'ai fait
ça et me dit mais tu sais long faire
quelque chose
aujourd'hui ce dimanche on parle t on
comme d'habitude je ne bouge pas c'est
ça qui fait tout le travail maintenant
ici est remarqué que d'après moi depuis
mon mariage ils nous ont emmené quelque
chose pour nous marier mais jamais je
leur ai demandé un saut 1 je leur ai
demandé d'emprunter dans certaines
occasions mais je leur ai jamais demandé
un sou
il était comme ça vis-à-vis de moi et
pourtant je l'aimé bien mon père j'ai un
homme exceptionnel d'une droite heures
tous et de leur histoire de d'europe la
wii va finalement qu'est ce qu'ils ont
dit qu est-ce qui monte avec l'europe
il faut absolument pour moi pour moi je
pense qu il faut qu'on change de régime
de distribution de l'argent parce que
l'art est il ya trop de différences
entre les bretelles et en s'étendant du
touch nom des communistes socialistes
tous rendus sans exception mais ce qui
m'étonne c'est que jamais jamais depuis
j'écoute à télé et ça fait ça fait
bientôt ça fait près ça fait 18 ans 1 eh
bien j'ai jamais entendu parler de
jacques du moins c'est des conneries
distributive le socialisme de
l'abondance qui avait une théorie ans
laurent grosso modo tu te rappelles à
peu près
elias était de de faire de l'argent de
créer de l'argent tous les ans en valeur
de la production c'est à dire par
rapport à la production est ensuite
d'argent ne plus nous servait qu'une ans
il fallait qu'ils soient ou dépenser ou
investis ça n'empêchait pas d'économiser
en investissant te dire qu'on pourrait
voir économiser en amassant
d'enrichissement seulement ce qui
m'étonne c'est que personne aucun pas
plus les socialistes que les communes
n'ont parlé de jacques dubois parce
qu'il fait les traites d'utopie un
jugement alors je ne comprends pas et si
j'avais été plus m je me serais permis
d'écrire à tu veux battre tu es pas que
je m'occupe de ça mais je me serais
permis d'écrire à je pense qu' un chirac
peut-être ou même mes mains jusqu'à ce
qu'on peut se permettre de gérer jusqu'à
1 sera on a trop l'occasion de dépenser
on l on dépense trop parce qu'on a trop
d'argent il ya trop d'argent distribué
chemise rester moins impressionnant
c'est mon impression
voir parce que
on pourrait tout de même s'arranger à
produire à faire une production plus
réglés ont fait un tas de choses qui
sont vraiment inutile
mais j'ai vu avec des indiens mais déjà
les
voir
remonter là pour me dire le monde
si
tu vois moi j'aime bien gagner mais ce
qui m'ennuie c'est que tu peux a trop
souvent c'est pas une des deux rendus au
brésil n'a pas d'importance un
mois jour pour jour un gay 1
jouer
lemonade avis no 2 de de catholiques qui
n'est ce pas et pis
baptisé marié régulièrement je suis un
peu un soin guila conservateur
enfin j'estime que c'est comme ça on est
bien obligé de le digérer nous on n'est
pas contre nos parents 1 et nos parents
n'étaient pas comme leurs grands parents
et tous et c'est une roue qui tourne et
il est possible que ça fasse que ça
donne un bon résultat s'il est possible
que l'essai au mariage cette utile
j'en sais rien je peux pas le juger mais
vu des divorces que l'on voit maintenant
il me semble en effet que ce point de
vue là je réponds mauvais des préférable
de faire un essai 1 alors quand on se
marie on sait ce qu'on fait beau rôle on
passait toujours besoin je ne sais pas
j'ai jamais très longtemps encore la
tâche et l'europe
en filmant
[Applaudissements]
c'était combien de fois les
schémas
temps 1
3 fois celle de la terre al 2002 soit
emplois par an lors un temps ça fait
quarante mille fois quarante mille
francs le feuilleton qui l'avait
je dirais que tout même la save et
meilleur son ménage à élever ses enfants
ce que c'est c'est mieux
un peu tout de même fm et la cmn a
commandé
puis les gens qui sont capables de tout
on ne peut pas généraliser non mais soit
non vous êtes des femmes qui sont déjà
supérieures à 100 mains des femmes qui
sont capables de faire ça il
n'y a pas d'égalité il ya des femmes qui
sont plus capables d'un homme non bien
sûr
le bonheur je ne veux pas on veut pas
citer non non ne choisisse un mois je
connais des femmes qui sont
beaucoup d'hommes qui fasse les faux
seins et même au point de vue au point
de lui même au point de vue pratique
compas d'une technique je suis cette
question d'apprentissage une question de
deux dispositions
précitées sa personne n'essaie de la
même façon 1 on a tous sa destinée et on
est en effet
comme on est quand on vient au monde en
effet comme on le sera et on y restera
[Applaudissements]
on a passé de bons moments ensemble la
famille aussi
un
méchant je ne vais pas les choses ça me
fait un beau saut mais aussi
le théâtre fontaine envie aussi eh bien
ces petits théâtres
je n'avais pas toujours les moyens
européens baneuil ainsi revendre à des
boulevards
cinémas gaumont
et disparus eh oui
caveau de la république
mais nous devons aussi mêlera nous
mènera le bal s'est révélé bien sûr que
ces
publics on avait droit à quatre heures
de spectacle pour 1 franc cinquante et
un bock de bière brune se visionner
qu'elle fait la beauté là bas alors un
horizontal alors récolté t ha de
céréales
moi j'en ai
[Musique]
s s au lycée millet deux mois mois est
mûri ds au n
vert des arbres alesi michel les
maintenant
nous sommes là nous attendons leur peau
alors rebeaud définitif 1
avec joie avec joints tong il ment sans
grain denis beurre c'est un peu la peur
de souffrir mais c'est tout comme ça
hein on a peur de souffrir alors pour ça
on est douillet en ont gelé pour lui et
mon vin seuls sept mois quand on voit
des malheureux qui s'ouvre pendant des
années avant de mourir
nous on est très bien et le jour faute
espérait d'ailleurs que d'espérer qu'on
me ravit timbre et l'autre parce qu'on
est indispensable là on est on ne peut
pas vivre l'un sans l'autre c'est pas
possible ma femme est indispensable pour
moi et moi je suis indispensable à ma
femme c'est pas vrai livre est un acte
on peut dire un acte d' espérer que ça
va durer encore cinq ou six ans
tu crois que tu as rome j'ai fini pour
l'hiver prochain
je ne sais pas tu sais pas mais ça
n'inquiète pas avant
dimanche 17h et médiatique
l'armée elle devançait tout entier
[Applaudissements]
droite heureux d'avoir beaucoup pas
beaucoup de désir 1 se satisfaire de ce
qu'ils ont mon principe tu aideras pu
travailler quoi un
essai mais c'est mais c'est mais
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]